I always struggle with this
question in part because I,
this is going to sound so cliched,
but I'm very forward marching and
that can be debilitating at times.
I feel like I have blinders on that are
just looking towards the future. Uh,
and sometimes that affects me because
it prevents me from reflecting well on
mistakes. But the first
that comes to mind, uh,
and this was not just a mistake,
it was maybe a collection
of what I perceived at the
time it'd be disasters was
in college,
Undergrad when I had a huge
dispute with my thesis advisor.
I also felt like I was being
funneled into one of two industries,
management consulting or investment
banking. This is at Princeton.
Very few industries come to recruit there.
And as a competitor I was compelled,
I felt compelled just as I had
in school to try to get a is etc.
To compete for the McKinseys
and Goldman Sachs of the world.
And I remember getting through one
round of interviews and just thinking to
myself,
I don't want to do either of these things,
but everyone else wants them.
Therefore,
perhaps I should want them to. And
that's a big, big warning signal.
That's a red flag.
It took me awhile to identify that.
And with the help of an entrepreneurship,
high tech entrepreneurship,
teaching them Ed Shao, Z, s,
c, h, a u, incredible man.
But due to the issues with my thesis,
I wasn't going to finish it
on time for a host of reasons.
If people want to learn more
about that, they can look up, uh,
some thoughts on suicide,
pretty intense and morbid title or some
practical thoughts on suicide and my
name and it should pop right up.
But I went into a deep depression
after leaving Princeton for a year.
So I decided to take a year off to
do two things to work on the thesis.
And I was told very
surprisingly by my advisor,
better be the best thesis I've ever seen.
In effect,
I'm going to give you a
terrible, terrible grade. Um,
and there's a lot of background there
I won't bore people with right now. Um,
but I felt like I was completely
trapped in a corner with that end. Uh,
on the positive side,
I decided to test working at
companies of different sizes.
So I worked at Berlitz for a period of
time helping to redesign some of their
Japanese instruction curriculum.
And I also worked at a political asylum
research firm and that was very small,
two or three people and I learned a lot.
So where it led me was realizing I
didn't want to work in a company of say
10,000 people or many thousands of people,
which Berlitz was,
and I was working remotely.
So I also realized there was a social
component that was really important to me.
I liked to work around people,
even if my team were remote,
I want it to be surrounded by people
and ended up at home by myself a lot.
And it was mentally destructive.
The political asylum research
was fantastic because it
really put my issues at
that time into perspective because
I was dealing with people who were,
let's just say homosexuals in a country
where they were going to be killed or
had been threatened with death where
family members had been killed or for
religious differences. And
they were filing for asylum
in the United States, uh,
to try to escape this type of persecution.
And my job was to find experts who could
be witnesses and determine what they
would call the meritorious
nature of these cases and, uh,
brutal work because there were
instances where their case was valid.
But for a host of technicalities or
process reasons in the U s system of
addressing such things, we couldn't help
them. And so literally it'd be like,
sorry,
you have to go back to this country where
you're probably going to be killed or
your family's going to be killed, or
your kids are going to be, um, attacked.
And that those very,
very brutal but very helpful at
the same time for putting my, uh,
first of all problems should we say into
perspective which Nola serious, uh, in,
in many respects I should point out I
don't fetishize that like a lot of people.
And the,
the very process of having to contend
with these existential issues,
seeing my classmates graduate a graduate
a year before me because I went back to
school, I felt completely alone
during this period of a year.
And it reinforced a few things for me,
like the importance of exercise.
So that is when I focused on boxing.
I went to this gym in Trenton.
I don't know if I've talked about this
stuff before. Went to a gym in Trenton.
I was the only white guy there. Uh,
almost everyone was on work release.
And I remember the first workout,
they're like, oh, let's see how you move.
They put me in the ring with this guy
who was a heavyweight and immediately
broke my nose and just bled everywhere.
And people laughed initially and
then they were like, Jesus, this is,
this guy's bleeding all over the ring.
And pulled me out and I kept training
there and that from that point on they
were fine with me. But uh, the exercises,
what kept me sane and that's when I
did the kickboxing training and so on.
That led to the nationals later in 1999.
That's when that was.
And that story ended up
in the four hour workweek.
So a lot of these existential
issues led me to make decisions.
Then this is leading to a better thing
coming back into school and continuing to
study under Ed Shell and
look at entrepreneurship
and starting my own thing as
the path as opposed to
having forged ahead,
perhaps looking back on it, trying to
spin it with some silver lining. If my,
if, if I hadn't had the issues in college
that I did that led me to drop out and
have all of that pain,
there's a very nontrivial chance,
let's just call it 60 70% chance that
I would have ended up at a Mckinsey or
Goldman Sachs.
Nothing wrong with those things.
There are some people who are just
hardwired to succeed in those environments
and they're perfect fit.
But you can't take an undergraduate body
of 5,000 people and just divvy it up
into two industries and expect
everyone to be a good fit. I wasn't,
but there's a very good chance I would
have ended up in one of those career
paths and I think it
would have been miserable.
I think therefore would not have been
terribly good at it and I would've had
ended up changing direction
five, 10, 20 years later.
And instead the universe kicked me in the
nuts and uppercutted me in the fucking
teeth.
And that was a good thing.
So in the span of six months,
I figured out what could have taken me
10 to 15 years to figure out. So, uh,
thanks for that universe. I don't need
too many of those in my life. Uh, but uh,
at the time, uh, that was a good course
correction. If you enjoyed this video,
I have more to share all of the tools,
tactics,
cool things that I'm finding five bullet
Friday. It is an exclusive newsletter.
It's completely free.
I sent it out every Friday.
Just has five bullet
points with the coolest,
most useful things that I found
or I'm revisiting that week,
and you can find it by clicking here.
Takes about five minutes to read.
Super Short, very actionable. Five.
We'll have Friday also
found@fourhourworkweek.com
forward slash Friday.